[Music]
Jamie Boyd congratulations you guys are
in the final round of this Christmas
themed competition now we're sending you
back to your home for just to recreate
this iconic weapon from history
the 1796 British light Cavalry saber
the 1796 English light Cavalry sword was
first used by British dragoons and
Napoleonic Wars unlike the suddenly boat
French Cavalry Sabers of the era the
English version had a deep curve whose
width increased as it reached the tip
although this design weakened the
Blade's thrusting capabilities it made
every slash heavier and more brutal
designed to inflict maximum damage
during large melees on the battlefield
the saber had the ability to remove
heads and limbs with a single stroke the
light Cavalry sword is the weapon of the
traditional wooden Christmas Nutcracker
and can be seen at the iconic soldier's
side in the latest film adaptation of
the Tchaikovsky nutcracker ballet the
Nutcracker in the four Realms you'll
have four days at your home forges in
which to complete this challenge at the
end of those four days you'll return and
present your swords to our panel of
expert judges after they thoroughly
tested your Christmas Sabers they'll
declare one of you the force and fire
champion and give you a pretty nice gift
[Music]
we're in Grand Rapids Michigan and this
is Vulcan Studios I'm going to start
with one chunk of 5160 spring steel and
I want to sandwich two hunks of leaf
spring to create a sand my Billet
the goal today is to just get to take my
ability put together and then stretch
out the build as much as I possibly can
so tomorrow I could really break it home
there it is
I officially burned my fillet into two
pieces and I am definitely falling
behind on the clock I have to make a
whole new Billet
I'm stretching the Billet and I see a
little seam that's starting to come
apart so I put the flux back on I put it
back in the fire
big crack up here I wouldn't say first
day wasted but
it's looking pretty close
I'm happy to be back home here in
Northern New Mexico Christmas
My overall plan right now is I'm doing a
Damascus blade out of W-2 and 15 and 20.
I started drawing out my Billet
everything on the power hammer is
working excellent so with the time I
have left I'm gonna get it cut stacked
and I'll loaded up tomorrow
I started my day off with 70 of
yesterday's Billet third time's a charm
just decided to take more leaf spring
put it on the outside of the bill to add
a little bit more beef and keep going
with the Sand by
one stick for whatever reason I could
not get the medals to fuse
my small failures are compounding into
catastrophes
it's Do or Die time
I have to start over again I go in my
junk pile and I find a nice two inch bar
of tool steel very disappointed I have
to give up on my original sand my
construction but I have to make
something that I can actually finish
forged out as far as I could go
I don't have enough material I'm about
five to six inches short I'll go any
thinner it's gonna be way too thin for
the final piece it's a real way to end
day two
morning your day two I got my steel all
blocked up ready to go
I think I see crap
[Music]
all the way down to about the center of
that building there's no recovering from
that they're just junk I have to start
Plan B
we're starting over
we're gonna go mono still with the 5160.
the plus side is
as far as drawing that a lot further
than it was I've lost half my day I've
been messing around with this Damascus
not to mention yesterday we're just
gonna go all out and move as fast as we
can see if we can catch up
I was expecting to have a quenched sword
blade by the end of yesterday I don't
even have the sword blade yet my
emergency plan is I'm taking two pieces
of mild steel and making uh sand my
Billet on the Tang end of my carbon
steel Billet in order to be able to draw
it out long enough
[Music]
man
I cannot believe this thing just cracked
on me oh he's the technique for it it
works but I'm running out of time I
can't just mess around with something's
not gonna work so I abandon it and I
just grab a leaf spring pressure is
really on
bye I'm gonna finish I'm either gonna
turn something in that I can be proud of
or I'm not showing up and I'm I'm
showing up I'm gonna finish blade and
I'm gonna go there and show them what
I'm made of
pump it didn't raise no quitter
today I need to finish up that handle
and guard setup and I need to
concentrate a lot on the blade I mean
ultimately this is a really light weapon
it needs to stay alive I do have a lot
to get done and a short amount of time
luckily I have my own personal will
Willis here so at some point today I
will get a countdown and let me know
when all of this is done
[Music]
good job buddy
[Music]
all right what lies ahead are three
tests there will be a strength test a
sharpness test and up first Doug is
going to carve the roast beast Doug
placements welcome to the kill test
keeping with this Christmas theme I'm
gonna take your weapons to deliver some
slashes and chops on this Christmas ham
you're up first you ready for this let's
do it
all right Jamie the first thing that I
noticed is the extreme weight
automatically I could feel the stress on
my hand it wants to fall forward now
let's talk about the blade this is a
chopper that gets work done in three
chops your weapon sir will kill thank
you
all right point where you're not here
and nice because it's your turn
I don't know we'll see
this proves that a light sharp blade is
just as deadly as a heavier sword
overall sir your Nutcracker saber who
killed thanks all right gentlemen it's
time for the strength test now to test
the strength of your Sabers I will be
chopping into this ice block
[Music]
Jamie you're up first you ready I am
the biggest issue I have with your blade
is its weight but for this test the
strong blade it held up so good job
thank you all right boy you ready I
don't know
foreign
still sharp it still has a perfect Edge
didn't take any damage that way but
we did pick up a bit of a warp towards
the tip I mean it's definitely
an issue it's not so far out that it
wouldn't cut everything else is still
tight and together good job yes sir all
right blade Smith now it's time to find
out there's any Edge left in your weapon
this is the sharpness test the Christmas
tree trim
to find out how sharp your edges are I
will trim this tree in the mercaida
family Christmas Tree tradition Jamie
you're up first you ready for this trim
away
it is a little bit on the obtuse side
and it's still heavy but on every stroke
I'm able to trim this tree overall sir
it'll cut thank you all right boy it's
your turn are you ready to do some
Christmas tree trimming
[Music]
your Edge is sharp and the weight that
you have for this I didn't have to reset
for every cut that I did I just go along
cut up cut up and cut overall sir it'll
cut thanks all right gentlemen the
judge's and I have had a quick
conference and they've made their final
determination about which of you is the
forge and fire champion and who has to
leave the forge we played Smith leaving
the forges
[Music]
Jamie
now unfortunately Jamie your blade did
not make the cut that's because it's
very heavy and unwieldy and for that
reason I have to ask you to please leave
the forge Boyd congratulations you are
the force and fire champion and that is
the title that comes with a check for
ten thousand dollars Merry Christmas my
friend anything to say to the world uh
Merry Christmas all right my friend come
on over and Shake our hand
I'm really happy the way that the sword
turned out I was a little nervous when I
saw it take that bin but I couldn't ask
for a better performance out of it ten
thousand dollars is a great Christmas
gift to me yeah it's going to be
exciting my son will be off the walls
probably for the next month and a half
foreign